[Musique]
dégradation des soins pénurie de
soignants épuisement professionnel les
urgences sont en crise une réalité
accentuée ces dernières années avec
l'épidémie de covin mais le malaise est
ancien à l'hôpital pour les services
d'urgence se l'épargné coup de colère
des médecins des urgences et du samu il
se met la tension monte aux urgences les
médecins urgentistes seront en grève
demain la grève des urgences dans
plusieurs hôpitaux à paris le personnel
tire la sonnette d'alarmé
retour dans les années 70 à cette
période les services d'urgences commence
à se structurer dans les hôpitaux
français
l'objectif faire face à l'urgence vitale
avec un personnel spécialisé médecins
infirmières réanimateur mais très vite
des dysfonctionnements sont pointés du
doigt le premier grief des hospitalisés
c'est la carence d'accueil des services
d'urgence il ya aussi la tante jugées
trop longues aux urgences le manque de
personnel et les locaux vétustes pour
juger de la situation le conseil
économique et social commande un rapport
au professeur adolphe steg en 1989 ses
conclusions sont sévères alors de quoi
souffre le plus les urgences des
hôpitaux as un manque de personnel un
manque de crédit ou un manque de
matériel se tient la foire et roche
l'alerté lancée résultat au début des
années 90 plusieurs lois sont votées
pour une réorganisation générale des
services d'urgence mais dans le même
temps leur fréquentation ne cesse
d'augmenter et les soignants sont
débordés en 1998 le ras-le-bol et
national les urgentistes en ont
ras-le-bol de la manière dont on nous
traite depuis des années il chez des
médecins qu'ils ne regardent pas la
montre dit des médecins qui sont
capables de faire 80 à 100 heures de
travail par semaine il faut que cela
maintenant soit reconnu au fil des ans
malgré les réformes de santé le malaise
100 ans aux urgences le quotidien décrit
par les soignants ne change pas horaires
à rallonge demander à quelqu'un de
travail et les trente six heures de
suite quel que soit le métier ça me
paraît pas normal mauvaises conditions
de travail c'est une élève de ras-le-bol
une grève pour revendiquer de l'aide au
niveau de notre travail
connor qu'on ne peut plus accomplir
normalement service engorgé actuellement
c'est à fretin du co qu'il génère il ya
plus de périodes critiques c'est une
période critique continue l épuisement
professionnel c'est un cri d'alarmé
parce que là certains d'entre eux qui
sont au bord de la rupture aujourd'hui
le personnel soignant alerte toujours
sur ses difficultés selon l'association
samu urgences de france les services
d'urgences en péril représente 20 % des
établissements du territoire
[Musique]